جورجينا ماتت توقف عن محاوله انقاذها لا
جدوى من ذلك جورجينا لن تعود لقد عانت
كثيرا من الافضل ان تستريح
سممت طفلتها البالغه من العمر تسع سنوات
فقط الطفله اصيبت بشلل الرباعي ثم فارقت
الحياه ولد اعتقال الام كشفت التحقيقات ما
هو افضل من ذلك بكثير
الاسم
التهمه قتل بناتها الثلاث المكان اليونان
في التاسع والعشرين من يناير عام 2022
توفيت الطفله جورجينا ذات التسع سنوات في
احد مستشفيات اليونان بعد ان دخلتها مرات
عده منذ ان عانت للمره الاولى في ابريل
عام 2021 من تشنجات مؤلمه انتهت باصابتها
بالشلل الرباعي ثم الوفاء سارع الاطباء
الى تشريح الجثه ليكشف الطب الشرعي ما لم
يكن في الحسبان ام الطفله وهي ممرضه في 34
من العمر تدعى رولا بسبيريجو صممت ابنتها
بمخدر الكيتامين رغم انها كانت تعلم انه
سيؤدي الى معاناه ابنتها لفتره طويله ثم
موتها القي القبض على رولا في مارس عام
2022 وعقب توقيفها باشرت السلطات بتحقيق
يتناول وفاه ابنتيها الاخريين بل لماذا
ثلاث سنوات التي توفيت عام 2019 ورضيع
ايروس التي توفيت عام
وكان عمرها حينها سته اشهر فقط
لتاتي صدمه اخرى الطفلتان توفيت اختناقا
على الرغم من استمرار التحقيق في مقتل
الطفلتين الا ان الاتهام بوفاتهما وجه
ايضا الى الام في اغسطس عام 2022 فيما
اصرت الاخيره امام المحكمه على براتها
اثارت القضيه غضبا واسعا في اليونان التي
من النادر ان تسجل حوادث مماثله وحضي مقتل
البنات الثلاث باهتمام اعلاميين كبير ما
دفع الحكومه الى الدعوه الى التحلي
بالهدوء اذا انتشار دعوات لقتل رولا لدرجه
انها كانت ترتدي ستره واقيه من الرصاص
ومحاطه بحمايه امنيه كبيره خلال نقلها الى
المحكمه وبينما ينتظر اليونانيون نتائج
التحقيقات وقرار المحكمه كتبت على واجهه
منزل رولا في مدينه باتراس عباره الموت
لقاتله الاطفال حتى انها لقبت هناك بميديا
العصر وميديا شخصيه خياليه تقول الاساطير
اليونانيه القديمه انها كانت تقتل ابنائها
بلا رحمه او شفقه